[Laughter]
hi I'm haunting from Microsoft Research
Asia and I want to talk to you about
haptics today we've all had the
following experience it's cold outside
so put on my gloves go outside the house
take out my car keys and I want to open
the car door with my remote I cannot
feel the buttons on my key because I'm
wearing a glove so I looked down take a
glance at the buttons press on it
the door opens the fact that I cannot
feel these buttons does not bother me
because I can always look at that key
and find that button and execute a price
now what if I tell you this is exactly
how we have been interacting with our
computers we touch that screen with an
ohm hand but we cannot feel anything
other than a piece of code glass we're
developing technologies that's gonna
enable you to not only touch but feel
that computer screen what we have done
is we want to create a sensation when
you type that's much more similar to a
key click not just an abstract sound not
just an abstract vibration so we do this
by taking the screen actually literally
off of that phone and put piezo electric
materials under the bezel now when you
have a keyboard you are typing on the
phone that glass literally bends
instantaneously very small bending but
that's enough to tell your finger that
it feels like a key click this is our
surface touch cover except it's only a
cover we have taken everything outside
and put different things in there
again we use piezo electric actuators so
when I send a high voltage to it they
buckle and that is the mechanism for
creating that sense of click under your
fingertip and we find that people do
type faster
and they make less errors when they can
have this kind of key click as compared
to just sound feedback which is
typically implemented in most of these
devices let me move on and talk about
feeling things on a screen so here I
have a checkerboard on a Lumia 920 phone
the black par feels a bit sticky and the
white part feels smoother now we do this
by putting a piece of glass on top of
the phone and we again use the wonderful
peers or electric actuators on top of
that piece of glass and we vibrate that
glass at very high frequency this way up
and down but what happens is when you
run your finger on that piece of glass
it can trap a very small piece of air
between your finger and that screen and
this is what makes the screen feel
smoother the last demo is very similar
we changed surface friction so you can
feel different regions as different
textures but we do this with a different
mechanism we call this electrostatic
haptics the finger tip is filled with
fluid here so when there's charges here
it attracts the opposite charges towards
them so that creates a force that posts
the finger down now when you move your
finger back and forth I can fool people
into thinking that something's happening
on that piece of glass I hope that we've
given you a glimpse into the future of
human-computer interaction where we can
not only reach out and touch but feel
what's on that computer screen thank you
[Laughter]
you